kezzal ma question s'adresse à monsieur
premier ministre j'aurais pu vous
interroger au sujet de la nomination de
la belle fille de monsieur jean pierre
jouyet
mais je vais vous interroger au sujet de
la prochaine nomination du pdg de l'inra
en effet l'institut national de
recherche à drew agronomique est une
très belle institution de recherche et
sa reconnaissance scientifique est
international pour notre pays notre
chance c'est notre agriculture
les enjeux économiques et sociaux d'une
recherche agronomique de très haut
niveau sont évidemment essentiel jusqu'à
présent c'est les cheveux qui ont dirigé
cette noble institution avait la
particularité d'être eux mêmes des
chercheurs reconnus et incontesté ils
étaient des managers mais aussi des
chercheurs exemplaires or il semblerait
que vous cherchez à nommer quelqu'un qui
n'a pas du tout se profile en
l'occurrence le directeur de cabinet de
monsieur le foll quelqu'un qui est un
apparatchik et non pas un scientifique
quel mépris pour la science et la
recherche je m'adresse donc aujourd'hui
à vous pour vous demander monsieur le
premier ministre
l'exemplarité du processus de nomination
du futur pdg de l'inra il est essentiel
que tous les candidats y compris
l'actuel pdg puisse présenter leur
qualification leur motivation et leur
vision pour la recherche agronomique
futur devant un comité de sélection
impartial
monsieur le premier ministre la science
française mérite bien mieux que vos
petites combines la parole de ta
monsieur thierry mandon secrétaire
d'état chargé de la recherche et de
l'enseignement supérieur finir monsieur
le député
depuis la loi de mars 2013
les procédures qui préside à la
nomination d'un candidat à des fonctions
importantes sont encadrées par la loi
et justement pour garantir la qualité
des candidatures et en même temps
l'objectivité et ce processus se produit
ce processus qui a qui n'avait que trop
tardé à rentrer en droit positif est
désormais en cours
l'appel à candidatures est temps a été
publié au journal officiel
il se il est clos en juin à mi juin 2016
ensuite un jury sera composé par la
direction générale de la recherche et de
l'innovation étudiera les candidatures
formulera un avis après quoi le candidat
proposé par le gouvernement viendra
devant les deux assemblées
parlementaires compétentes qui se
prononceront par un vote à l'issue de
quoi enfin le conseil des ministres
prendra une décision
faites donc confiance au droit fait donc
conscience aux règles qui ont été votées
par cette assemblée et la décision qui
sera prise sera forcément la bonne
puisque l'émanation de la compétence et
de la ville de la représentation
nationale
merci monsieur mans dont la parole est à
monsieur pierre-yves le borgn'